three months ago i put out two thousand
dollar call for artists to expand the
world of demon souls
to create bosses environments enemies
and law
for the icy lands beyond the northern
limit for in demon souls there are six
worlds to explore but one of them
is lost behind a broken arch stone
according to cat content in the game
this was supposed to lead to the
northern limit
a human frontier on the edge of the land
of the giants
it's a world of ice outlandish creatures
and
perhaps answers to some of the deeper
mysteries in the game
and regardless of whether this area is
added or the archstone repaired
in the upcoming remake i wanted us to be
able to imagine and
visualize this place and as always you
guys delivered
what i'm showing on screen are such good
entries and
while unfortunately none of these made
it into the top ten they came so close
and we debated long and hard about each
of these so i want to start with them
one of my favorites was by mache janik
who
depicted a night exploring a lost castle
a place that was gifted to the giants
who ended up abandoning it because these
giants had no need for such shelter or
material wealth
another place that scored really highly
was by john bick
who beautifully rendered 3d scenes that
looked like they could actually come
from the upcoming remake and how could i
not mention
ab and rain a dual team of artists who
designed a dual boss fight as well
telling the story of the two small
figures who stand at the foot of the
broken arch stone
this was very similar to another entry
by natalie
who also brought the two smaller figures
to life
except this time they were the children
of the grim matriarch
demon the queen of the northern lands
who hides an insectoid demon
behind her poise and her grace but in
the end
only one could be chosen to officially
start our top 10 countdown today
and i'm so excited to say that it's
the iron baroness by titanilla pizzfor
this is the first boss you to encounter
as you journey into the northern limits
and she guards a temple inspired by the
cut content from intruders
indeed we see their remains here
soldiers from an old war with the giants
frozen to the floor where they stand for
her long ornate battle halberd leaves
behind frostbite as she swings
for a charged aoe attack that leaves her
really vulnerable she can also summon a
flock of these
shadow birds from the cut content which
are themselves an enemy that
you need to kill as they fly towards you
when she's close to death
she'll enter a more aggressive phase and
her eyes will turn blue
hinting at the light of the shadow men
which burns behind her mask
this is a really cool twist because the
shadow men are also creatures that
feature prominently
in the cut content and it explains why
she's so tall and slim
this piece intrigued my curiosity and
man while i wish that curiosity was a
little bit more rewarded with a longer
law entry
aesthetically at least this might just
be the strongest entry
and i'm not gonna forget the tall
striking figure
of the iron baroness one piece with a
really powerful narrative
was by tim kelly which takes us beyond
the broken sixth archstone
to a land that has had its fabric of
reality broken
which is indeed exactly what the arch
stones were created to
uphold i had a life once a family
that life was stolen away one night i
felt an inexplicable dragging
a tugging at my soul to go north as i
trekked past the northern limit i lost
all sense of time
flashes of lucidity cut through moments
of terror and cold
a fear gripped me that i did not know
and ever more my journey became
incomprehensible i remember towering
stone structures
frozen wastes blackness and then out of
that terrible
fog a city it was warped bent by unseen
hands
behind the shimmering landscape through
mist and snow
i felt her i came to call her the weaver
for the world she made had been woven
from the fabric of an existing one
in the shadows i felt her presence the
queen who had made this place her
dwelling
the city was beautiful i felt connected
to it i understood what it was
and what it had been it was the city of
the giants but it was not the same
the weaver had twisted it along with its
inhabitants they stood outside the city
in shadow and fog
i felt their fall on gaze remnants of
their old pride remained
left behind as a cruel joke within the
shadows of the city
things changed the walls became trees
roots quaking with desire to devour
i latched onto things i knew to stay
grounded a piece of grass
or a rock but those things too were
twisted i kept finding myself staring
into the dark
a part of me desperate to go deeper even
now i yearn to return to that place
despite the fear
i may get to feel her again as some
believe the old one to be a mercy upon
humanity
so too do i believe the weaver to be
responsible for bringing something new
into the world for now she resides
beyond reach and recognition
atop the tower she has woven soon you
shall all
see i felt like the quality of that
narrative would really speak for itself
and while it's a little bit far from the
cut content concepts of the competition
we all loved this beautiful surreal
outlandish take
on the land of the giants this whole
area was cut from the game
but some enemy models still remain in
the files
well in my opinion they look a bit
underdeveloped and
off many artists actually took advantage
of that and
chose to polish these designs that's
where d-raw comes in
here we have their owl sorceress weak to
fire
and wielding this wooden catalyst it's
rendered in
incredible detail making it probably my
favorite enemy design
in the entire competition these shadow
birds are the inhabitants of d-raw's
take on the cut content castle
but where draw excels most is in
character design
so let's talk about moru the elder giant
moru was one of the last elder giants
gifted the archstone but also
responsible for its destruction
for the deep fog was coming and even
though he smashed the archstone with
enough force to dent his giant cleaver
it was all in vain the deep fog attached
itself to him
and started to corrupt him in demon
souls the deep fog
is actually said to be spread by the
demons themselves and
i love that d-raw actually shows this
process
in his entry with the fog stemming from
the corruption
on moru's left side interestingly this
also affects the gameplay
if you strafe to the right into his
shroud of fog
then you'll take damage over time but if
you strafe to the left
towards his weapon then you'll be open
to more attacks instead
gimmicks like this are so important to
demon souls because this is a game that
has
a lot of boss gimmicks and they almost
always have some
exploitable quirk that makes them
interesting to fight
as this fight progresses the corruption
spreads and similar to the fight with
artorias
moru starts to fight like a beast
throwing aside his weapon
pouncing and spreading the deep fog with
reckless abandon
tied for seventh place with d-raw is who
you might remember came third in the
last competition with his rendition of
new londo
as before he uses the arrangement of his
pieces to tell a story
and this time we immediately identify
with the player
who enters a fog gate flanked by these
enormous pillars
and huge headless bodies littered before
it
their heads lie beyond the fog gate and
there are huge swords pitted in front of
them
but your eyes aren't drawn to this
they're drawn past the giants
to a giant slayer named hught a human
who ironically now towers above them all
hught was one of the commanders in king
allan's great army
but after the gruelling war with the
giants hught opted to stay behind
and he never returned to his homeland of
bolitaria was he blinded by hatred
and driven to slay all of the remaining
giants or did he
perhaps stay out of guilt that last
sentence casts this shadow of doubt
and indeed um claims that hewt was
racked with regret
and gave himself this heart-rending task
of beheading the giants
and making tombstones of sorts for them
with the swords that they once swung in
battle
this idea is reinforced by a little
gameplay twist where
if you resist the temptation to roll
around and destroy all the boxes in this
glorious display of particle physics
then if you don't do that huet will
speak with you
instead of fighting you we especially
adored the armor design here
which mirrors the armor of duran and i
loved his weapons of choice
a one perhaps for giants and one for men
this piece
marks a common trend in this competition
which is
the theme of humans committing really
evil deeds
and the whole race of giants going
extinct as a result
but one whose entry really broke the
mold
is icy with the widower
and the husks one of the cut content
speculations about the giants
was that they might have been a very
tight-knit communal civilization
since their archstone was granted to
them all rather than just
to one ruler icy honed in on this point
and created giants that were so bonded
together
that they actually take damage for each
other not only that but he interprets
the word
giants plural to mean that there are
only two
giants not necessarily a whole race as
we would expect
an abandoned journal in the wastes tells
of a man
exploring the frozen land after the fog
had swept through
he writes that he's looking for a stone
which we can assume to be the archstone
perhaps
and he goes past cities erased by fog
past beasts that hunt in the night
and he looks down over a ledge and spies
a masked black
demon so tall it scrapes the sky its
skin
is burnt from the snow the grooves on
its body are cracked
and it's surrounded by these weeping
husks it locks eyes with the man
who shrinks away and runs back to his
camp terrified
the next day in spite of himself he
returns to this place
and realizes that there are actually two
giants and one of them
is a corpse of a female lying on the
ground as he watches
the masked giant places its hand on its
partner's cheek
collapses to his knees and shrieks in
unison with all of the husks
filling the valley with sound to the
man's shock the female's chest
begins to rise and fall she was alive
and she's breathing
but looking down once more he sees the
husks turn as one
look at him and cry out brother come
down
you really have to read this one for
yourself the writing is incredibly
haunting it actually echoes lovecraft
all the way up
to the twist at the end furthermore the
gameplay also has some demon souls
gimmicks
you can fight the giant by slashing at
its heels or you can actually damage it
by hitting the bonded corpse before it
instead which is a little bit easier but
it will infuriate all of the husks as
well
if you read it you realize i see is the
god of narrative
and their full entry will stick with you
if you take the time to read it all
now all of these pieces are very high
concept
by which i mean they feature significant
bosses
big implications for the series and
really core concepts for the land of the
giants
but man not every entry can feature the
deepest law
sometimes we have to appreciate the
simpler things you know the levels that
lead up to these places
and that's where the great ravine by kyo
comes in the great ravine was once the
safest passage from boletaria
to the city of the giants that said it
was still dangerous
with dozens of conflicts between giants
and humans
fought to the taste of metal left upon
the tongue by a strange gas
that permeated the ravine but in one of
these conflicts something happened that
would change this place forever
a chance spark ignited the gas
triggering an explosion of flames along
the entire length of the valley
killing giants and humans alike and
completely altering the ecosystem within
from that point onwards
since then the temperature has risen
great geysers of scalding water erupt
from the ground
and from the depths of the caves a
creature they call the putrid cockatrice
has emerged rumored to have been the
source of the terrible gas
now a new race has taken over this place
they're called
scavengers fragile photive beings that
all of a sudden found themselves able to
flourish here dressed in the pillaged
armaments of the humans that perished
and wielding shards of giant bone the
scavengers hide from the demons in their
caves
but they also use traps subterfuge and
the difficult terrain to take down their
enemies
if you were to travel through this place
as a player you would have heavy objects
thrown down upon you
from their homes which are built high up
from the ground
and the scalding water you would have to
somehow get up there
all the while fending off their
domesticated dogs and the wild creatures
of the scorched ravine at the end you'll
come face to face with
putrid cockatrice trapped in the depths
long ago by the scavenger tribe
who now worship it as a deity that
helped them thrive
in the northern lands it fights with
claw and mouth
and it still exudes large amounts of gas
that deals damage over time
so you should probably think twice
before using any fire based attacks down
here
lest you fall into the same peril that
the soldiers did
all those years ago huge props to kyo
for creating such an imaginative
early game level it really helped me to
connect with all the late game levels
that
most artists opted for one of my
favorite renditions of a late game level
is the giant colony by sebastian
francini
which drops the player character into a
seemingly untraversable land
which is a credit to the vast landscapes
of the cut content
as you advance vast planes give way to
awesome valleys
a natural maze with the higher reaches
dotted by doorways that lead into the
homes of the giants
in the past giants dominated this land
and could be seen quite often
but somehow after the first scourge
most were killed or imprisoned the few
that remain are close to death
but that is far far preferable to the
death that they face
to the end boss of this area so they
hide away in their caves
to avoid being seen throughout the
valleys fly spectral ravens
birds that are altered by the dark magic
that has conquered this land
and to this end these ravens have
incredible sight
and can spot their prey from miles above
at which point they'll core so loudly it
can alert others in the area
another enemy that's been adapted from
the cut content are the mimics which you
might remember
sebastian explains that they're the
shapeless remains of former humans
who have been tortured by the soul arts
and stripped of their conscience
and spirit all of this just does a great
job of arousing your curiosity as to
what or who caused all of this and
the story that sebastian provides is
extensive it's well written
and it's rewarding stationed at the
northern limit to defend the giants
king alant and his brother radiel
launched a series of expeditions into
the northern lands
to gather the giant's knowledge on soul
arts this lust for power led the king
into a temple
upon the highest mountain from which he
never returned
years later riddell's wife followed
alan's path
drawn not by greed but by an invisible
force
when she reached this place the secrets
within were too much to bear
and she too lost her sanity and never
returned
ridiel back home learned of her fate
from the maiden in black
who communed with the old one and
learned that his wife was not dead
but worse she had become a servant of
the old one
an archdemon who had turned the old
palaces of the giants
into a place of soul harvesting there
the peaceful giants were fed to the old
one
save for the strongest who were
resurrected in necromancy to serve as
slaves
perhaps if the slayer of demons manages
to destroy
what remains of riddiel's wife their
souls could be saved
it's a joy to have the world of the
sixth archstone fleshed out so
imaginatively
and as we crest into the top three we
are reaching
entirely new levels of world building
and
perhaps no one does it better than zen
cloud
the world building god what makes this
title all the more impressive
is that zen didn't design a single
environment instead
zen builds his world through his 28
characters
and their accompanying text for example
these are his giants
kazu the tower a walking city aki the
beacon
who guides lost travellers makoto the
silent
sentinel guardian of the northern limit
sen
protector of the pale forest tomo the
borrower
friendly to humans and dormir the newest
creation
of them all for these giants were all
created by a pygmy race
who lived in the northern limits long
before any human
and who have an innate magic called
flesh shaping
which is a unique sort of self-defense
system
by consuming the bodies of the deceased
pygmies can create what they call
white mud which can be used as a
sculpting material
upon a willing participant so the first
giant they created with this was
kazu the tower who had thousands of
pygmies living inside of him
for a time but that was before the soul
wars which precipitated
the fall of the giants ulf the mountain
king
desperately needed an heir and so with
the flesh shaping of the pygmies
he created one it was named ridiel
which means horseman in scandinavian so
a fitting
state named asper was also made for him
as a gift
however in a twist of fate ulf actually
had a true born son
a year later named bragi who was revised
to be the heir to the throne
when the true story behind ridiel's
creation was revealed
upset at the nature of his fake
existence
ridiel was persuaded by ambassador
lorraine a demon in disguise
to fabricate a story about how the
northern limit is planning to invade
boletaria with the solars
and so the soul wars began king oath
also had a demon misguiding him culpa
the advisor who feeds on guilt
beset by demons and with the king of
boletaria bearing down upon him
the war was lost both his sons were
killed and
alant shattered king of soul into pieces
one of which became anger a fragment of
his soul
furious at the death of his sons then
the soul wars
awoke the old one and the following
demon war wreaked further havoc upon the
land
and its natives the pygmies with only
the giant makoto
to defend them all perished save the two
who busied themselves creating a new
giant named
dormir the alkyn sorcerers succumbed to
demonic corruption
the central fear who created radial soul
fought back by creating berserkers
infused with beastly souls
and the sawmill cutthroats thrived
switching sides for gold
and devouring the natives whole there's
so much more
but these were my favorite parts and i
think i covered most of the art that i
described
but i encourage you to download this and
read more in the art linked in the
description
congratulations to zen cloud on coming
third
for second place we enter the lost city
by christian reyes
a piece that instantly grabs your
attention inspiring you to read about
what you've witnessed
all the way to the end the first shot
has you a mere dot in the landscape
standing before a giant demon beholding
an even more colossal gateway
it makes you feel small which is a
valuable feeling when exploring the land
of the giants
and after defeating your first headless
demon you approach the gateway
in the second shot and realize how
littered it is with the swords and armor
of fallen warriors clearly the battle
was fought for this place
the third shot as you walk through to
the outskirts of a city
sheltered in the overhang of an enormous
glacier this
is actually a really neat reference to a
rare environmental detail in the cut
content
where an overhang is supported by a
giant pillar of ice
a green glow draws you towards a cave
and here
you're supposed to fight the second
headless snow demon
which is stronger than the last and can
attack with swords
rocks and bodies from the landscape
around it you'd feed the boss
and make it inside the cave here the
architecture becomes a bit more surreal
with inverted
aztec-style pyramids built up to the
cave roof
these are aspects of miso american
culture and there's also a theme of
being suspended upside down
and both of these things are
foreshadowing for what's to come the
fifth shot
reveals an immense ancient city inside
the mountain with a blue light in the
gateway
casting this otherworldly light on the
colossal pyramids to either side
here details become a little denser and
you can spy demons lurking in the
shadows
and peeking over the tower all the
creatures are unrecognizable
save for one the last headless snow
demon
in times past these were the three
leaders of the giants
something that's alluded to subtly in
their tattoos and attire
but when the colorless fog came turning
everyone into demons
they had to make a choice should they
live on and become
powerful demons or should they sacrifice
themselves please the gods
and prevent their bodies being used
against their people
in keeping with that meso-american theme
they chose sacrifice
and taking a blade to their abdomen into
their neck
they died then they became demons
regardless
accelerating the end of this civilized
world it's this perfect little twist of
tragedy and
you know this might surprise you but i
actually really like that stuff
if you're looking carefully you might
find recognizable elements on their
shadowy backs
and also in the background of the fifth
image which is a final sign
of what's to come a blue light from the
main pyramid calls the demon slayer up
the long stairway
to find that within suspended upside
down
quite clearly having been tortured is a
dead old one
the first to ever exist i love that you
understand the tragedy here
without really needing to be told
anything but to help flesh out the
narrative
directly underneath the ancient being
you can see someone called
the maiden in white turns out this old
one
created life as we know it all the way
back when it was still alive
things were peaceful and so the gentle
oldest one
began an eternal slumber aided by the
maiden in white
in the time since civilization grew and
the leaders of men
called the monumentals discovered the
ancients lair
and offered protection to this powerful
being i love that christian hints at a
sinister origin for the monumentals
something that the game does as well so
it's really smart to bring that up
here they built a kingdom around this
ancient being
but they experimented on it craving
knowledge of the soul arts
realizing her deception too late the
maiden in white awakened the oldest one
but it was dying so with its last breath
another old one was awakened
and it was this second old one that
began the first
demon scourge a response to human greed
to fight poison with poison of course if
you know anything about demon soul's law
the first scourge was resisted and the
arch stones were created to seal the old
one
there was peace until the second scourge
but christian goes on to explain the
second scourge too
for he explains that king alant tracks
the giants to this city in the mountains
where he finds the maiden in white
knowing full well the greed of men
causes its own downfall
she teaches alain to the soul arts
willingly this time and the second
scourge is inevitably triggered
the old one awakens again and the events
of demon souls
are set into motion diving into the law
behind the first and second scourge
is such a great idea and the concepts at
play here are
absolutely phenomenal i love how the
vengeful maiden in white
and the benevolent oldest one are the
reverse of the benevolent maiden in
black
and the vengeful old one i love the
internal consistency in this piece
as it draws from miso american culture
and the cut content
and i adore the environments that
christian created
this is perhaps the most atmospheric
piece in the whole competition
and for a game like demon souls that is
a wonderful thing
to achieve you can find christian reyes
on artstation
and instagram where he'll field your
inquiries and commissions
and if you've been listening at all you
know i can't recommend him highly enough
this art is a great extension of the
talents that we saw from him in the
olden ring art competition and
i really hope we see him take place in
the next one as well
but finally for first place we have
this drawing my son alou did on his
etch-a-sketch
magnificent okay for real how could we
not
give first place to jane
we've listed many gods in this
competition and
jane would have to be the goddess of
quality and quantity
for not only does she submit video music
lore 2d art 3d renders in-game shots
vertical slices
maps level selection screens map
blueprints npcs and art breakdowns
all of it is somehow good as well
like don't get me wrong you don't have
to contribute this much art to win
usually it's actually better to just
submit a few pieces of art and
make sure they're all your best work but
jane
somehow has the capacity to contribute
this much stuff
with no missteps at all and that is
something to be applauded
so let's start at the top of her main
image this vertical slice of
two-dimensional art
with the old one soaring above it all
below is the nectar shrine
where maidens were taught to refuse
worldly pleasures and to direct their
sight inward instead
to this end initiation takes place at
the candlepot
held by the godly maiden whose three
sets of hands
cover her eyes perform magic with the
phosphorescent pole
and pour wax down below to permanently
seal the eyes of the receiving candle
maiden
of course this means that there are more
than just our maiden in black
there was once many maidens with newly
initiated maidens wearing white
and darkening their garb the longer that
they pray and learn
in the corner of this image is the
maiden in ashen who used all of her
strength to draw you here
through the broken archstone she needs
her help for the shrine is overrun by a
cast of evil alchemists
who are hunting down and experimenting
upon
her sisters defeat the corrupt alchemist
who jane interprets as this character
from the cut content
and the ashen maiden will spirit you
away to the ruined land of the giants
so that you can learn from the past this
was once a sacred land of pilgrimage
and the first npc you'll meet is one
such pilgrim
who stands before the body of a giant
and tells you of their deaths
to giant ballista and forbidden magic
for humans craved knowledge of the soul
arts
and fought this race for their secrets
here beastly humanoids
once allied with the giants are hostile
to you immediately
and this area culminates in a fight
against the last giant where
you have no choice but to bring him down
the third and final location
brings us to the frontier of the
northern limit where we discover who was
responsible for the evil delivered upon
this land
you walk in to find yourself in a grim
dark castle
where an npc a young girl tells you
dreamily that the new ruler of the land
lord radiel's nephew is very pretty but
that no one has seen him
in a very long time the girl sells a lot
of cures for poison
and rot which is excellent foreshadowing
of what is to come
the next in-game shot places you before
a frozen magician
who's frozen in place in a desperate
attempt to seal off the throne room it
shatters
revealing a party of knights turned to
stone and kenneth
archdemon of the northern limit after
lord radiel's imprisonment in the tower
of latria
kenneth took over affairs at the
northern frontier and
inspired by his uncle king alant kenneth
took to the soul arts
supporting allan's awakening of the old
one by becoming an archdemon with the
dedicated cult of serpentine followers
maidens for worship and soldiers for war
he commanded the extermination of the
giants
and demonstrated that any of his enemies
were destined to be conquered
what an entry jane is a master of every
medium
so if you need someone with varied
talents for your project
you can find her contact details and her
art station
in the description below i'm honored to
be able to award her first place
and to reward her and others in the top
ten with their share of two thousand
dollars
quick shout out to my patrons here you
guys make it easy to justify
dropping thousands of dollars on artists
so thank you
and for those of you that do appreciate
this art soul of cinder patrons who
pledge for three months or more
will now get this great art i
commissioned called skyward swords
sent to you as a poster so if you're
interested in supporting
and getting something like this then
look into the description for that
as well the most painful thing about
these videos is the artists who came
so close but only just missed out so i
also want to take a moment to give
credit where credit is due
please continue watching and please
check out all of this work and more
in the description below special thanks
to angelica for being the first
front-runner in this competition
giving me hope for what was to come well
done to michelle for contributing some
of the best gameplay concepts with giant
beasts that rear up from the snow
and a series of boss battles in an arena
nolan
as always you provide utterly fantastic
concepts and
we loved your sculptor hewn out of this
rough pillar who created the sixth
archstone only to break it
once he became disillusioned with his
past work
holdsworth hands you had the best pixel
art and your story and concept work is
getting better and better
jessica you had a rare take on world
tendency and
honestly some of the best concepts in
the competition
mark your take on the yeti enemy was
incredible
marianne your 3d work detailing the
monumentals will stick with me
maxwell zack and chris your planning was
unparalleled and
getting richard on board was a fantastic
idea
and to everyone else on our list of 32
front runners
keep an eye out for an email because
you're all very likely candidates
for the sole arts book that i want to
make which
i view as an opportunity for me and the
judges to
actually give you the credit and the
presentation
that your work really does deserve but
even if you weren't featured in this
competition
know that i did see your art i
appreciate you
and i respect you so much for just
having the will to complete
an entire piece of work and also the
bravery to just
put yourself out there finally enormous
thanks to the judges for this
competition
john devlin who has helped in every
competition including this one
i couldn't have done it without you and
also thanks to our new judge
ricardo amike which should be a familiar
name to some of you
he brings the insight of an artist who
has placed first
in these competitions a couple of times
so you can find both of their artwork in
the description
and in the comments section below anyway
study up on bloodborne
artists because that is where we're
going next and it might just be the
final art competition
for the foreseeable future thank you for
watching